November 26th 1983 McAvoy and a gang of
six robbers head for a lucrative target
Brinks Matt a storage facility for money
and precious metals near Heathrow the
city's main international airport among
McAvoy's gang is Brian Robinson a
seasoned professional criminal on this
job he's arranged for inside help these
were all known names who were career
criminals not chances had robbed before
successfully robbed before McEvoy's goal
is three million pounds in cash stored
in a double locked vault inside the
warehouse getting access is easy the
gang has employed inside help a security
guard lets the robbers in Tony
Brightwell is among the first
investigators on the scene they were
masked they were armed with sawn-off
shotguns they shattered orders they told
the guards to get down on the floor the
gang gives the guards a stark choice
open the vault door or die they pull
petrol over a at least two of the cars
and threatens who torched them if they
didn't call Frank McEvoy was certainly
making great show of holding a lighter
near to them the cash is stored in a
safe paused in a vault as far as getting
into the safe was concerned it required
a combination number two guards had half
of the combination number each one of
the guards was so petrified that he
actually had a mental block and forgot
he's part of the combination number
no combination no cash then the gang
makes an amazing discovery they saw
pallets on the floor of the warehouse
which contained boxes about the size of
his shoebox and found out that there
were gold bars in these boxes it's an
incredible stroke of good luck the gold
has been packed for shipment to a
customer now I don't think they were
prepared for this amount of gold the
gang has stumbled upon nearly 7,000 gold
bars over three tons
ready for delivery the haul is worth a
staggering two hundred million dollars
in today's money
it's the biggest gold bullion robbery in
British history
MacAvoy has pulled off the crime of the
century but the gold is about to give
his gang more trouble than it's worth